the Champions League final comes around
at that point you're playing Spurs how
confident were you going into that we
knew 100 we knew like there was no way
that they beat us there was no way we
knew we were the much better team
[Music]
what are your memories of your Liverpool
debut
I wasn't expecting at all we'd had a
couple Cup games before that against
like lesser teams and I remember when we
drew them I was like
off a sniff there because you know when
we played betting uh you can lack all
the rest The Lads you play in the league
and blah blah but it never happened so
where would you Tottenham
and obviously I'm thinking no chance but
yeah I remember him pulling me in um
just before training and said love you
to start and yeah I remember me when I
don't call me family and saying I'm
playing tomorrow
I'm Stalin's moral
like to get to the game really so and
the game itself like walking out of the
tunnel what were your emotions then
Chris emotional but I want to just
stepping out of the fish it was just I
don't know it was just laughing over rad
and feeling of pure emotion that's like
this is it
that's what I worked hard for how did
the game go like did you think did you
feel like you had a good game that day
yeah yeah I got tired early though I
came off like 60 65. and
but no I'm definitely definitely done
well
yeah one two one as well so yeah
yeah what about any any like particular
moments from the game that you remember
why you might have got substituted for
example
uh uh yeah I mean yeah there's a that's
yeah so obviously I think I think I
should have got I should have got sent
off really but I've always heard stories
like the excitement and like the the
rush tackle and like your first game and
your first derby and blah blah like you
just get over excited and you do like
craziness and I thought I'm just like
quite unlevel-headed like there's no
that won't happen to me
and even going into the game I was quite
calm and I thought it don't need to
worry about all that and then just I
don't know where I've just
yeah I just flew into a town and Brash
rash towel didn't really The Tackle was
on yeah and so full-time whistle goes
what was the the emotion then for me I
had that I'd achieved my dream you know
that was that was the dream of the aim
coming to the academy with so many
players who you know
don't make it who are better than you or
the ups and downs of the academy I'm
putting in all that Hardware all that
sacrifice
like I said it was just everything every
every single thing that I've done and
it's it's like you know yourself what
you what you've done I think no no one
else really knows at that moment it was
it was all so worth it
so you've made a Liverpool debut
what did that drive you on then to to do
more or was it a case of right what I'm
in now I can you know I'm a Liverpool
first teamer nah because I always had
the fear of going back to like the
academy that's what normally happens
is you dabble with the first team and
then and then you go back down
and even still I think even at that time
I wasn't even
I wasn't even full-time at with the
first year when those two separate
changing rooms there's like a first
thing changing Reserves it's on a daily
basis me OVA thermal band with all that
kind of be up there and just every day
uh pep lenders
will come in and say yeah use it back
over here tomorrow
so it's like every day we're fine to
stay up there I think Looking Back Now
like the coaches and the managing that
they probably knew that we were up there
but in our minds every session was could
be at last and you know when you're
there with your teammates you're like I
don't want to be the one going back
today and you still coming up he doesn't
wanna so yeah I think it was just like
we were fighting so hard it was a river
moment you didn't think you'd make it
and was there even an alternative no I
don't there wasn't a specific moment
that I didn't think I'd make it but I
think you know for the majority of our
players in the academy that's that's
that's the that's reality that's why I'm
so passionate and so I'm working so hard
within that space with the after Academy
to then help these young players who you
know
get released and don't have that plan B
and don't quite know where to go with it
it's giving them the opportunity to
you know have a career soften that that
blow of having the dreams
um dream shattered
and just being there for them
foreign
[Music]
the Barcelona game
first leg in at the new camp didn't go
to plan to be to be fair what was your
feeling after that game I didn't blow so
were you out there watching yeah yeah I
just I managed to just bench me I think
a lot of games and I don't know he
didn't really give a reason for it just
thinking like
obviously I just thought yeah that's
what I'm not now
that's done was that the feeling in the
team as well
it's hard to say it without saying bad
but it was almost like we didn't really
care that much like it should it didn't
feel like we've been B3 you know is what
I'm trying to get our I suppose it's
like we didn't quite on the we didn't
really like comprehend the situation we
were in it was like
I don't know it just it it never really
sank in that we were three and all down
at that moment
so then fast forward to the second leg
what was the feeling going into that
game for the day before
the boss's second leg on the Tuesday was
City Leicester on the Monday night
my company scores the the screamer as
you do you check out like check our
City's fixtures and you kinda
pinpoint where you think they might drop
a point
and like we'd all agreed if there was
going to be a place it'd be Leicester
that will cause them the biggest problem
so we thought you know that that that's
what it is if the if they get up to
there with all wins and they beat
Leicester
Stone and it just it can they just felt
like it was all against us you know
are you there you thinking
we've we lost one game all season
away
so if you're gonna lose one game that's
where you lose it like didn't really
drop any points
gonna be on 97 points at that point it's
live
this this is this isn't fair
um so like we all go in train in the
morning
and again at that point it's life
we've got nothing to lose now we've got
nothing to lose like not like might as
well go for it it's just like
let's just play and then the game itself
at which point do you think okay we've
got a chance here was was it was it a
moment say the third goal
Mr Hangul gave us we were like got a
chance but we get another one get it's
extra time or pens whatever
the third goal once that went in I knew
we knew we were going to win it was
there was no way you could stop us at
that point but even two at halftime won
the Lop
they've had they've had a few chances
and stuff Ali's made on real saves and
like we were still quite calm we weren't
excited about it it was
get the next goal and it the gaffer said
you know it doesn't matter when it comes
it's just be patient if it comes 46
minutes or 85th doesn't matter and then
again full-time final whistle goes
excitement relief what's the overriding
emotion there yeah it's like a crazy Joy
crazy Joy but you don't quite know
what's what you don't quite know the the
magnitude of what just happened well the
best part of it was
the following day going into training
the following day
and I've known that it was real like in
that night you don't quite it doesn't
quite feel real
and then you wake up
and then like on your way into training
it's like
you're smiling let's say you're smiling
then you see all the lads
and it's like that was real like what if
we actually just done
it's a Champions League final comes
around at that point
um you're playing Spurs
how confident were you going into that
yeah it felt right it's just felt right
if I'm honest we knew 100 we knew like
there was no way that they beat us there
was no way there was there was not
really any doubt amongst us it wasn't
that we were screaming from the rooftop
saying like yeah we've won
it was we do our job proper we all do
our jobs
there's no way the Beatles we knew we
were the much better team
if we played well like we win and the
only way we don't win is if we play bad
and they play outstanding so it was just
about making sure we played well what
was the game player going into it that
night obviously after what was it two
minutes you go one the lap did that
change how you approach the game yeah a
strange one the other the other players
meeting I want to say
maybe on this Thursday but we hadn't the
only final we've been in is the
Champions League final the year before
um which was a strange one and how they
handled
winning the game
taught us so much
anyway then we spoke about what happens
like how to handle different games
scenarios and the first thing you saw
was like what do we do for taking nearly
lead don't change your game plan
easy thing to do is on such a big big
occasion you get an early lead and you
think I need we need to protect this and
you sit back and just invite pressure
and we like we said to each other look
we can't do that because that's not the
way we play we just played the game that
we needed to play there was nothing too
special about so we defended it defended
well
and done what we needed to do to win and
then the box scores the second goal when
that go goal goes in it was right in
front of the Liverpool fans as well
well how did that feel
it's hard to describe it for honest it's
the best feeling I've had on a football
pitch I think like the disappointment
from the year before added to it just
the joy of knowing
that we we've done it always
an incredible feeling
[Music]
it seemed like Liverpool and you and you
yourself are playing regularly
against the team at Manchester City both
winning every week did you feel that
gets the best out of you or would you
rather be playing against the team that
you know probably aren't as good yeah
I'd rather be weren't that good but I'll
probably have a couple more medals but
and I think we
think we got the best out of each other
and I think we've taken
the league to the next level to a level
it's never never been before and had to
title races that
arguably oh
best the best ever let's go back to the
season when you finished on on 97 points
and still slightly missed out
unbelievably throughout That season was
there any moments that you thought we
we've got them here we're gonna do it
we're gonna do it they never slipped but
really let's be honest
they never really slipped up so there
was never there
there was never that we're gonna we're
gonna get them here it was always just
the hope
and it just never
just never came you you obviously you
won the the Premier League
um with 99 points a season after
um what was different about that season
do you think to be honest I think the
Champions League win helped us that
season
I think if we if we didn't win that then
it could have been a psychological blog
but
we lost the Champions the year before
it lost the league basically on the
final day
it was it at that point it didn't really
affect us after the league finished I
thought it's fine next season over there
and then so you get the trophy you get
the celebs but what's the feeling is it
is it relief is it excitement how does
it compare to winning a champions league
for example it's different because we
want it
way earlier than when we got the trophy
that's always different you've got time
you you have weeks you've already been a
Premier League winner so it's
although it's good to get your medal and
the trophy nothing beats getting it
straight after you've just entered
[Music]
for any season my season
in the best place in the world
I think that's achievable and that's
kind of
an expectation now
whether people agree with it or don't or
don't think I am if I think I am
and then I know I play to a level that
is top 10 top five in the world then
I'm happy with that I'll tell you what
he is he's a better person than both of
them by far the way he pees the ball
about Phillips better password than
rodri
you think that rodri is a better park
pass to the ball than Phillips I'm going
okay